[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode Kos
it's a date
I bring you probably one of my favorite
all Incredible Hulk statues this is
known none other then sideshows Premium
Format now we'll double check that
because a lot of your guys in fact
checking me Incredible Hulk now the
reason why I got this statute is because
one of my favorite artists the South you
simmer sob you simmer originated that
wild hawk that strong Hawk look in the
comic books
Sabu Simmons Hulk was it became iconic
it especially became iconic to me for
the simple fact that he was able to make
splash pages splash pages just be all
pages sort of like this where he's
smacking Captain Marvel with the back of
his hand a lot of young guys don't know
who Captain Marvel is and when we get
into a couple of my other statues I will
go into depth in depth on who he is and
this is also a little bit of insight on
why the emcee use age of Ultron as a
Marvel comic universe
MC use um age of Ultron is my favorite
Avenger movie is because we got a
glimpse of South you Simmons savage Hulk
now and also I believe this statue is a
derivative of that age of Ultron even
though I have another statue that's an
age of Ultron Hulk that wall will be
showing at another time but this one if
you look at the base the base has the
hulkbusters hand that he ripped off at
the base that is kind of monumental
because it shows you the level of
destruction this Incredible Hulk is one
of my best books from South view summer
was king-size annual that's what needs
to do an annual at the end of the year
and give you the biggest bang for your
buck and it's king-size annual number
eight The Incredible Hulk vs. sasquatch
now they set it up with the Windigo the
Windigo is a mythical creature that
ranges in the northern hemisphere who is
it inhabits a human's host and it turns
into this giant woodland creature that
is always or normally white and they go
out and they kill and eat so the hulk
landed there from one of his are fights
as many fights and landed in
area and not unbeknownst to him
Sasquatch has been sent out to figure
out what's going on in the area with
these killings and stuff but he also
wanted to test his mic against the hole
all right and that he did as we know all
the Hulk wants to do is be left alone
and Sasquatch gave up an epic battle now
such parts is from the Alpha Flight and
he is an orange creature that is I think
twelve feet tall over a thousand pounds
he's a man that can turn into it he can
hold his gamma radiation and actually
change into the Sasquatch but he also is
inhabited by an entity hopefully I can
get that statue I would really love a
statue of Sasquatch and so social sites
show if you're listening please this man
wants that I want all the incredible
Hawks battles
so they actually pitched the battle and
really the hawk wanted to be left alone
and the Hulk beat him so bad it's one of
my best books but also I have a couple
of books like this right here where
thought-through
swung his hammer the Hulk and the Hulk
or this hammer in his hand wild thoughts
still holding it and just crush the
hammer it's one of the instances where
those hammer got smashed against you
know great odds but you have to
understand the level of power that the
Hulk was admitting at that time to do
something of a feat of that nature so
this is the reason why the Hulk is my
favorite character exude strength he
doesn't want to attack anyone he's
really provoked the man never goes out
of his way to look for
but when trouble shows up he's more than
willing and strong enough to handle any
type of trouble that comes his way so
back to the statute if you can look at
the Vantage on the arms of this statute
it's insane
as they also did it in a way where it's
a darkish green so you can see the veins
bulging it's like he just went on a
rampage the face looks like a sob you
sell his artwork the hair is like moved
to the side is like he just finished
coming in destruction and it's very
powerful the open hand
it's gripped up it's very powerful the
fist is ready to you know to attack I
needed to have the statute as soon as I
saw it it's mixed media the shorts is
made out of material you understand what
mixed media is if y'all have been
following me for a while and know the
difference between mixed media and poly
stone that's mixed media and it's um
it's it's a beautiful statute so a lot
of times people ask me you know King how
do I go about you know purchasing
statutes this look different levels of
purchasing statutes you know understand
did there's ways of getting into who's
your favorite company I would say do
your research or sideshow onion Studios
XM prime one I have different statutes
from different companies and I'm looking
for you know for different things from
them a lot of times they're commissioned
into doing different statues for you so
mainly you find a distributor mainly
sideshows a distributor of a lot of
these companies so a lot of times I will
direct the person to go to sideshow now
custom statues custom statues you get
back you go on Commission and they're
done by Commission and you usually go
through back channel ways of getting
these statutes
I usually if I'm getting a custom statue
I talk to the commissioner
I also talk to the artist and I find out
if they want me to talk about where I
got the statue from and how they can
obtain it if they want to obtain it and
talk to me in a DMS and I will steer
them in the right direction and that's
up to the discretion of the statue maker
so you guys see it and I love this
community I love all the love that we
receive and it's just a fantastic way to
show my fandom to show my passion and to
bring it across to you I hope it's
getting across to you in the same way I
feel it in my chest because as a child
growing up I used to run home to watch
the Incredible Hulk and some look Bill
Bixby a still of his transformations
every Hulk movie I watched just to just
to see the hall you know and he's one of
my characters because he's a reluctant
hero but when time strikes he's there so
and he's and he was been all on the
major teams like the Avengers the West
Coast Avengers the defenders so you know
the Hulk is a staple and also you know
he started his own group I like the new
cartoon shows that have the Hulk in it
he's an iconic character it's a shame
that we can't see him truly how he's
supposed to be and
you but that's you know because
illegalities you know and one day maybe
that'll be rectified and we can get
world breaker Hawking which is probably
the strongest halt right now they're
doing a comic book called the immortal
Hulk and I wouldn't really love a statue
of the immortal Hulk um this is the part
of the video where I may ask you to like
follow subscribe also go to loads of
gaming that net what we have a ton of
opinion pieces articles that are up by
our stellar staff that is writing
beautiful laws stuff I mean I just read
something the other day and it was
amazing I had to retweet it out because
seriously I'm not just saying it because
I'm a part of it I'm saying it because
it's true if you actually get a chance
to go there you will understand that
that stuff is amazing also we have hard
gaming reviews by Lord addict that is up
there more episodes of Kos and we also
have the last world where low kognito
and pontus that stuff is amazing but all
the looters shooter stuff going on right
now and really want to dig into that and
it's worth your time so again this is
King the Kos urging you to keep
collecting and see you next week stick
around so you can see the statue on all
its glory and you can listen to some
good music and look at some good pitches
and watch video take it
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]